i want to back up a second though talk
about these empathy triggers that we
were talking about earlier
we were talking about the way that they
create these tribes right the tribes of
the other
and the oh yeah and the bad and the way
that people
uh absorb information and then believe
something without understanding
it it's because we're being sorted now
into tribes based on empathetic triggers
so think about it you see a video and
one person
if you're in this tribe you feel a
certain way about you know george floyd
and the knee on the neck or whatever
or you see a video of somebody coming
out of a store with loot in their hand
and you get an emotional trigger if you
believe in black lives matter and all
this thing and you see somebody looting
you're like yeah man you know just
destroy get it whatever
but if you're on on the right side you
see that and you just feel immediately
like rage
and so we're just being bombarded
constantly with these images that are
supposed to elicit this
emotional response out of us that's like
deeper than
than our voice or our speaking or our
our self-talk right it's empathy is in
dogs and animals and chickens and
whatever
it's in us too it pre-dates language so
we can communicate with each other
through empathetic
triggers and that's what's happening
with social media with the videos with
the internet
and we're all being completely sorted
based on our empathetic responses
to the same kind of images and that's
why
it also triggers this hate as well and
there's just no reasoning behind it you
can't
reason people out of it when they're
responding on a level
that's like below language oh yeah
reason breaks down
what if you're taking empathy well when
you when you get angry you're you you
don't
think logically so there was a uh i was
reading the story once about it's like a
u.s
naval vessel that was sank and all the
soldiers
you know or sailors fled to the life
rafts
and then one guy everyone's freaking out
he pulled out a service up and
dismantled it took out all the bullets
and then gave everyone apart and said
shut up we're gonna rebuild this and
then everyone was confused and he's like
shut up we're rebuilding it
go and then they had to piece it
together and that was a survival
training to put people back in a logical
state of mind to get them out of the
rage
the panic mode so then they start
thinking i have to wait for my name to
be called so it puts them in a
systematic
that allowed them to think clearly and
rationally come up with a plan and and
survive longer that's very smart that's
actually a fantastic stress
management tool right there but
assigning everybody a piece
saying call your name giving people jobs
and it does yeah yeah it does
so okay if our people love jobs i want
to keep talking about what you're
talking about but i want to talk about
say this real quick that
if like in the matrix it looks like if
if we were
automating jobs away and it's going to
like what is our job now talking into a
camera or whatever
and then in the future like what's your
job just give using the heat that your
body produces to create electricity
and then they put them in tanks and
you're just plugged in that was so dumb
yeah but that was like their job became
just to produce heat
their body and maybe that is our
ultimate jobs
well think i mean look to be fair that
that dude i've got his name in the
matrix who wants to go back in
right the guy with the steak and the red
wine yeah the red dress he's like just
put the red yes
cypher cipher yeah yeah he's like you
know what what is
joey pantalone exactly what was the joke
he said you know why everything tastes
like chicken
because the machine's never had real
meat before so they just make everything
taste like chicken
something like that but i i i i
empathize with that with that idea that
that he's just put me in the machine
where i just
generate heat and get to live a normal
life you know what's the point of being
flushed out into the nether world of
you know weird robots and eating sludge
and stuff
for me i'm all about freedom though i
was gonna say where would you go i've
already established that i'm comfortable
being other
um counterculture and i like to resist
the mainstream sort of
themes would you want to be in the
matrix or would you want to be in the in
the spaceship
trying to find zion and save the world
and free
everybody from the matrix where would
you be red wine red dress red steak
no i'll tell you what man you know the
best part about uh getting out of the
matrix is
you can control your own virtual
realities if you're outside of it
so the people who were in it were doting
about normal lives with limited control
but it was like
calming i guess because that was one of
the points that the rope the smith made
in
in the matrix that they gave humans
paradise and humans rejected it
because it was not normal but the people
who leave the matrix
can have that thing going to their heads
or whatever and then they can create
their own little virtual world so it's
kind of like
hey i'll tell you what man you get to go
out life's not easy
i'm okay with life not being easy and
then but then you get really awesome
breaks where you can learn kung fu
instantly and stuff i gotta show
everyone this comment oh snap
is a guy and he's got a it's a packet of
silica gel do not eat and he goes
those silica gel industry big shots
can't tell me what to do and then he
eats it
the next one is him with like a cap on
with electrodes and he's like shocked
and there's two doctors and one says
congratulations you've escaped the
simulation
welcome to the real world don't eat
silica jelly don't do it
industry big shots can't tell me what to
do now going back to empathy triggers
yes
i think social media and these
algorithms are
exacerbating that corralling definitely
a hundred percent and it's
it's it's gone beyond uh political
networking it's gone beyond emergent
political networks but like
hong kong or chile or france or whatever
now
we're moving into tribes bro it's the
aliens
try do you think so because if our
brains are receivers
check this out and all your brain's like
a bunch of neurons of electricity that's
very sensitive to other
electricity and you know what if
something's beaming
something to our brains like if
obviously the sun's beaming light to us
but what if there's the galactic core or
something or
some more intelligent generation
generation is like interacting with our
brain they're more like radio
transmitters that are
they're tuned in to the right frequency
and then behaving the way that the free
and so when you're writing information
and your brain is like
growing you're actually writing a new uh
tuning
uh shape that's receiving different
information
that's just wildly speculative it's like
the joke i was making was like yeah
you're talking about how we're being
corralled
and i was just like like sheep we're
being corralled like sheep like someone
is you know they got they got a stick
and they're flapping it and there's like
a dog running around and barking at us
and we're going oh
we're all running into little corrals
where we're being neatly tribalized
but what's also happening talking about
empathy triggers it's interesting
people who are likely to get angry
people who are likely to get sad
people who are likely to get angry at x
people who are likely to get angry at
why
are all being put in bubbles that can be
mapped out
so these data networks are really
interesting where they take they do
visualizations of twitter
and you'll see democrats and republicans
and like republicans smaller but like
really tightly packed meaning they agree
more with each other and the democrats
are very spread out
and so what happens is it's like you
were saying you show someone a picture
of
you know george floyd some people react
x some people react y
and they all immediately cluster and now
we've created we've we've
strengthened the borders around the
different types of people
the different emotional reactions all
neatly packaged and quantified
the joke i was making was that aliens
are shepherding us i don't think
why would we be doing that to ourselves
accidentally
we're not exactly is it such a thing as
an accident well yeah yeah
the the the systems evolved to do
whatever we thought they were going to
do we created this social media network
darpa started on it whatever we got here
but now this is like emergent phenomenon
you know people figure out something
that works
and then people repeat it and repeat it
and repeat it and repeat it so
in a way we are doing it to ourselves on
purpose and then
the meme makers the mean magicians the
people that control
narrative they are definitely doing it
on purpose
okay 100 100 well so so i've been
thinking about
that's what we're doing especially right
for sure so like uh my main channel is
like
typically democrats are doing this and i
don't like them for these reasons
but you know i've i thought long and
hard i'm like first of all i do think
there's criticism towards me same as any
other partisan who's producing content
because they're focused on something
they don't like
but what i think it is it's not that uh
i'm making things up no no the democrats
are doing
screwed up things nancy pelosi got uh
republicans to cave on the coveted
relief bill and even jake tapper and
wolf blitzer were like
why won't you say yes but why is nancy
pelosi refusing to say yes
for for tribal reasons where she's like
but trump did this
i'm not going to let him win on this so
then i see that and i go haramf
then she gets mad and so there's a back
and forth where
arguably you know different pockets of
you know of other tribes are morally
justified in certain things
and then people are getting outraged at
the other you know what i mean it's a
tit-for-tat
it's a never-ending cycle of but you did
screw us over on cover belief i
am mad about that republicans didn't do
that and then
nancy pelosi does something but the
tribalists defend her and ignore what
she's doing because they're more mad
about donald trump
and his reaction to kovid and so then
they complain about trump and co but you
see how
like this machine keeps churning yeah
and and the influencers the people that
are driving
this i like to consider them and i got
this from john robb who is a networks
analyst and a special forces guy wrote a
great book brave new war you should
check it out
and uh he he and i have been had a lot
of conversations and one of the things
we've come to the conclusion is that
the influencers the leaders were
narrative curators
right so like information is everywhere
and ubiquitous in fact there's so much
of it we don't want it there's
there's too much information and it's
completely irrational to think that
individuals are going to be able to sort
through all that information and figure
out what's what
so an easier more efficient way of
sorting people and getting people into
places through these empathetic triggers
and then the people that can control the
large groups they're the ones that can
curate these empathetic triggers and
curate narrative
in a way that causes people to coalesce
and once
you control the narrative it can control
these empathetic triggers you can
literally control
masses of people millions of people mobs
in the street
go to war vote for this guy change the
country go that direction
through i mean it sounds so silly
remember 2016 people were like
oh i survived the meme war i'm a meme
more vegan yeah yeah right it seems so
silly then but actually if you think
about it now it's actually very very apt
i i believe it is fair to say that 4chan
memes trump into the presidency
i'm i'm not kidding i'm not saying they
got him every single vote but they got
trump votes
with trump's hair was there were funny
things that would pop up that someone
would see
and then someone else would would laugh
and be like make your own
laugh join the fun and people were
laughing and sharing memes
and it probably got a bunch of people
who are like probably mid to late 20s
who are like you know what i like what
i'm here and i like what i'm seeing this
is fun it's funny i'm in a good time
and those memes swung opinions
definitely swung votes
i mean you know as well as i do and you
had alum bakari here he knows as well
too that i mean
magic there is a connection between
gamergate
4chan the issues on 4chan people coming
onto twitter
all these people who are on these
unfortunate coming onto twitter finally
the whole gamergate fiasco and literally
that was the trajectory
that sort of led to the meme magic that
brought trump into power i was i was
talking to somebody a friend of mine
about
uh the split you know like the tribal
cultural warfare stuff
and she was telling me you know if we
bring people together we can end this
and i was like
uh i hate to be pessimistic but i don't
think you can
bridge that divide anymore i but the
split happened you know in the late
2000s
what ends up happening is it's like i
was saying you know like i'll see them
do something and say i'm i'm i'm sick of
this i think the republicans are bad but
can you believe what the what the
democrats are doing
like especially covered relief is so
important they're blaming mitch
mcconnell oh i'll criticize mitch
mcconnell for adjourning the senate
until the ninth
i think they should have done something
but the problem was nancy pelosi would
not accept them constantly giving her
what she wanted
so if you go all the way back in time
gamergate stuff before that how did this
gamergate happen
it was a gradual tit for ted tribes were
slowly forming
and then uh i've mentioned this several
several times cgp grey has a great video
called this video will make you angry
explains how the the the memes and
like the the arguments are not made so
he's like consider it like
one side our butterflies and one side
are flowers they actually help each
other become more
angry and and extreme in their views
because what happens is
the you know one side they all argue
with each other
about the other side so you have both
sides
festering and bouncing ideas around
about each other and never actually
crossing over and talking to each other
so that just makes the divide get
crazier and crazier and crazier
and then every day people say them them
them and complain about them
and everybody's doing it and everybody
feels justified in doing it myself
included
yeah and if you remember you know people
that have transitions like myself and
others that went democrat to deplorable
on amazon.com
if you if you have a transition usually
it's because of some sort of traumatic
experience that happens to you
something so bad has to happen that you
are willing to let go of your ego
attachment to your mental framework
and you're willing to re willing to
reconsider a different
perspective and what i am concerned
about right now and i've just witnessed
it by tipping
dipping my toe back into facebook and
talking to my old normie friends
is that it what traumatic experience is
going to happen to them in order to have
them
shake free of their ego attachment to
this mental framework that's been
inserted into their brain unfortunately
if it's not an individual instance it's
going to have to be
a national instance and and man
you know who knows what that's going to
be or when it's going to happen
you can bridge the divide alien vision
you know
i talked about that yeah but you know
some of us are going to want to
just shoot nuke them you know from you
know nuke them
in orbit yeah nuke them in orbit or
something we're going to welcome them
others are going to think
it's going to be divided then too you
know i think it'll be the aliens will be
you know they'll have some kind of
ideology called you know
glorbabism and americans are going to be
like we welcome the aliens but
they got to assimilate if they want to
come here and the left is going to be
like they come with wonderful technology
across the stars i think we can hear out
their idea you know and
be welcome that's it's always going to
be the same things i thought there was a
moment that kovid was going to be the
aliens that brought us together back in
the end of february or early march
that was against china that yeah you
know that lasted for like i don't know
four seconds hominids like
evolved you know like homo sapien is new
relatively we used to be all kind of
different hominids
things like over 40 000 years something
and then we annihilated the other
hominids
so even though even the
yeah yeah yeah like um neanderthals uh
homo florences like we just
killed homo sapien sapien was a sub uh
there's like
seven other homo sapiens savion out
there i think that they then they died
off so if we don't bridge the gap i
think
that part of us are going to evolve and
then hopefully not annihilate the
old ones but this is this is an
interesting argument about who would
ultimately win in a major conflict
the collectivists or the uh
individualists and there's a good
argument for the collectivists
you think absolutely but they've lost
every single time so far
it's you know it's
it's tough i don't i don't know you have
to come together there's a good argument
not a definitive
well right but fighting for other people
or fighting for yourself which happens
to benefit other people is a very
powerful difference and very powerful
but so
so why is antifa allowed to continue
this this you know reign of terror
oh well that's easy because they people
love the destruction that they love the
distraction
they have they want to be able to blame
donald trump for the listenings like
they've got allies that act in concert
and protect each other
whereas you know so the media is
absolutely defending antifa and and
black lives matter rioters
now journalists will talk about the
riots for sure but there are major
components of say like the new york
times that
will justify it there's there's the book
in defense of looting they have
powerful media allies and the thing is
the really simple way to put it is when
i say that journalists will cover the
riots
those journalists are allied with the
activist journalists who defend antifa
overtly
not with conservative media so there was
a story i was reading
earlier from san antonio express i think
it was about project veritas's expose on
expose on the uh
voter fraud stuff and the whole thing
was just ridiculously
uh poisoned well like veritas released a
heavily edited video he they've been
accused of deceiving and running smear
campaigns like before they even told you
what they saw
they were making sure you hated veritas
that is mainstream media allied with the
activists
if a conservative outlet publishes news
mainstream establishment media typically
says
go aft yourself that's the power of
collectivism
so conservatives do have their
collective it's true there's like
interesting moments where conservatives
form collectives and
we're seeing rallies for trump and stuff
like that but what's interesting now is
it's
there there are things that look like
collective behavior that are really just
emergent phenomenon and emergent
networks that have people who have
temporarily momentarily aligned
interests
and therefore they're willing to work in
concert with other people in order to
achieve
this goal that they have in common once
the gold dissipates then
the alliance dissipates the goal moves
well that's true yes
talk about that's why they're not for
free speech anymore that's why
it was the left protesting the world
trade organization the battle in seattle
and now they're in favor of
international trade that's why the
democrats used to say we need to
regulate and now you've got all these
democrats saying but the private
platform
their tribe just said we're going to
realign in this direction
and it's funny because it was a tit for
tat republicans have a real reason to
want section 230 reform on big tech
because their their constituents are
getting banned for saying innocuous
things like learn to code
the democrats then must take the
immediate opposite reaction of
but my private platform we should agree
on this yeah but no
it's always about being the other and
the gold moves well if we want to throw
out one major criticism of donald trump
is that he did not move quickly or with
enough strength or with enough force to
actually protect the people that helped
him get elected over social media in
2016 2015 etc
and it's a little too little a little
too late it's because the rest of the
senators are all taken by corporate
interests moneyed interests
nobody really really wants to implement
antitrust
no one really wants to crack down on the
corporations they're all getting money
from them
and if trump had actually been smarter
about this earlier on then it would have
actually helped him quite a bit trump
could have done one thing
he could have just signed up for minds
but i mean it yeah i was with bill
ottman uh
co-founder along with ian of mines
co-founder of mines
i had no idea i'm on mines let's do it
let's do it so uh i was with
bill we went to the white house it was a
social media summit oh yeah
and someone said will you sign up for a
alternate platform and trump said which
one
and a bunch will start saying things and
it's like i don't care what it is i say
mine's ian's in the room
yeah parlor but they're not free
software they are also alternate
well i'm saying software is a big deal
all i'm saying is if trump
right now posted something
saber-rattling
you know oh those russians are in china
and he put it on mines
the media would be forced to report
about it and then all of a sudden people
would it would be massive press for a
new platform that would attract massive
user bases
and it would offset the the the monopoly
held by these other
what was it called the big three i guess
facebook five or whatever twitter and
youtube google oh google is it google
youtube youtube twitter facebook social
networks so
trump could snap his fingers and just
totally
you know twitter was dying before trump
came twitter was losing users they
didn't know what they were gonna do and
then trump came along
and then trump started tweeting and they
loved it yeah and it was great and
started bringing all these people to
twitter
and that actually to be fair that's the
one thing i think trump inadvertently
has to take
uh well he i will and i will what's the
right way to phrase this
it's not his fault personally but the
action did lead to the mass
tribalization through twitter and the
fighting and all the stuff like
if twitter just went away we'd be a lot
better off
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time